[Music]
right everybody welcome back to the bear
trap podcast my name is John Kirby uh
this is going to be another solo video
uh actually it's an introduction to gex
spot so I actually recently did an
interview with uh Jas uh Jasper the
creator of gspot um and this is another
part of that Series this is sort of more
of an
educational uh introduction to The Tool
uh and as part of that I'm going to be
talking about Gamma exposure in general
for those of you who um are Avid
listeners of the podcast of which I know
there aren't too many but um those of
you will already be familiar with a lot
of this gamma exposure stuff but you
might still learn something new what I'm
trying to do here is to provide um an
introduction which um dives into the why
of gam exposure why all this stuff works
um with the interview with Jasper we
sort of did ran through a little bit
more of the how right how to read it um
sort of more how to trade it that sort
of thing um and so this is really sort
of that fundamental
important uh understanding of um what
the tool is saying uh what it means when
it's saying that and I think that that's
really important I don't think it's
worth skipping over and just jumping to
using it because whenever something goes
wrong right if you don't know uh what
the basis is then you're not going to be
able to understand what happened and
you're not going to be able to correct
for your Stakes Etc so I think that
really understanding this part of
options is very
important um the other thing to say is
there is a lot a lot of gam exposure
content out there so um this is by no
means going to be the most exhaustive or
the best uh there's a lot of resources
like um spot gamma gamma Edge um any any
array of gamma names articles online uh
whatnot the bear trap Discord itself is
a great resource as well um but uh what
I'm trying to do is just provide
something relatively short so that
you'll be able to get a deep dive
quickly and and know more or less what's
going on um so you'll see on my screen I
have gex spot up already it's running
live um and uh this is just kind of
where we're going to start um so for
most of those of you who have traded
options before um you know right that
like options are distributed across
strikes you can buy a call or you can
buy calls or puts you can sell calls or
puts um and so there's those essentially
those uh four possibilities right for
really really basic possibilities
um then in order for those transactions
to happen you also know that well
somebody has to be on the other side of
them right like if you're going to buy a
call somebody has to sell it to you
right because these are uh fundamentally
contracts between people uh or
institutions or whatever um and it's an
arrangement that we make if I buy a you
know 4090 SPX call from you expiring
today then you know I make uh I make uh
$100 per point for uh every point at XPR
above
um
so um a lot of times um that was me
drinking coffee by the way uh a lot of
times when people talk about Gamma
exposure they talk about uh the market
makers um and what they mean by market
makers are or whoever's on the other
side of that transaction and the
implicit assumption there is hey most of
the the people or most of the entities
on the other side of that transaction
are um larger entities uh which are uh
performing the function of giving
immediacy to Market participants right
so for instance if I wanted to buy a
very specific option and there was
nowhere out there nobody out there to
sell it to me it might take me a really
long time to make that transaction
happen whereas if there's an
intermediary and that intermediary is
buying and selling uh options all the
way along the chain all the time um then
they could sell me the option that I
want and compensate with two of a
different option so essentially bringing
buyers and sellers together um what ends
up happening though and the reason that
people talk about market makers when it
comes to gamma exposure is that um there
uh is often a sort of a buildup of
inventory um and then that's what we
call exposure it essentially means well
so many people have transacted so much
of this thing um that if the market were
to go in a particular direction say in
this case above 4090 if we've all bought
4090 calls well whoever's on the other
side of that is going to be in trouble
leading to the uh anabatic gamma squeeze
um of course it's important to remember
that hey actually um market makers are
on you know different size of many
transactions all at the same time so it
isn't as simple as saying oh this is
like this is not a simple
characterization of Market maker
inventory not at all um rather um what
we're doing uh and and I'm going to get
into this in a bit is just sort of
monitoring the overall traffic um and
the intuition behind that is Market
maker or not it doesn't really matter
the point is that if you sell an option
uh you're taking on more risk than if
you buy an option because if you buy an
option you know exactly how much money
you had to put down whereas if you sell
an option um it could go against you and
if it could go against you depending on
which option you sold you could be in
for way more than you originally sold it
for um and so the idea is that there's
an asymmetry there right sellers of
options in general um have have greater
obligations or in theory they ought to
be more cognizant of their obser of
their obligations and hedge them better
than option buyers um so that's how I
jump over the whole Market maker
non-market maker debate um and I think
that's a much simpler way to think about
this okay so granted we want to monitor
overall inventory um why is it you know
at in the first place that we're doing
any of this monitoring like why is it
that this is relevant because of course
like five years ago nobody cared about
this
stuff uh it just so happens to be the
case and I'm sure that most of you guys
have heard about this um that um some
there's some crazy statistics like 44 to
50% um of overall no notional value uh
dominated by um like overall notional
value
traded on the index itself whether it's
spy SPX whatever um is concentrated in
uh zero DTE options in other words the
point is um an easier way of saying this
is it used to be the case that uh large
share transactions transactions of the
underlying in addition to other factors
mostly controlled the price of the
indices now it just so happens to be the
case that there is so much volume of
options and there's so much leverage in
that world and the options are operative
on such a short uh time frame that it is
the paradigmatic tail wagging the dog uh
the options are moving price and um so
as far as all those volumes are
concerned you know you don't have to
take my word for it um I don't have it
up now but you can take a look at cdoe
they have great statistics on this stuff
um as far as gamma exposure or rather
sorry options being the tail that Wags
The Dog the easiest way to see that is
gamma exposure and um you kind of have
to spend a little bit of time with the
markets themselves in order to see it um
so you know that's not something I'm
going to do for you obviously nobody's
going to do that for you if you spend
time with a tool uh you'll see whether
it makes sense to you or not I'm just
here to sort of explain to you um give
you an introduction as to what it's
looking at and how to understand it uh
in any case um let me actually jump over
for a second to an option table because
that's what we need to do in order to
start to understand what's going on with
this chart so here's just like a
you know an option table from the
CBOE um and uh right we have like all of
our familiar uh bits and pieces it
doesn't really matter what strikes we're
looking at or anything like that it's
just the important thing is just that
we're looking at a table so we have bid
ask for calls uh bid ask for puts um and
then we also have uh volume which is
right here so it's how many uh contracts
have been transacted so far today and
then we have int or open interest uh
usually uh
we refer to that as oi and open interest
tells us how many contracts of this
particular option were open um as of
left open as of the close
yesterday um and then you also have your
options Greeks right a lot of you are
familiar with Delta gamma of course
we're going to be focusing on gamma a
little bit here um but let's let's think
a little bit about Delta first right so
uh options are weird right because an
option at least a standard option
uh it's it's not for one share it's for
a 100 shares of the underlying but the
weird aspect is that we don't know if
it's going to expire in the money or not
um and so the whole idea behind um Delta
is that um it's a you know fancy
equation black strolls and meron
equation uh there's a lot of different
uh there's like binomial models there
are different models that you can use to
calculate these things but essentially
what it's trying to do is it's going to
tell you um if your option were shared
right then how many shares would it be
and the reason that that's important is
because if let's say that you know you
have a 490 call and spy is or SPX in
this case is trading at 490 you can see
that you know it's kind of where it was
and so you have 048 Delta that means
that uh this option is simulating 50
shares meaning that if the uh price of
the index were to move up by one it
would be as if you had 50 shares in
terms of how your options going to
appreciate but because of the uh binary
nature of options in other words expir
in the money or not and if it doesn't
expire in the money then it's worthless
um there's this interesting phenomenon
where as you go further in the money
Deltas increase towards being 100 right
towards one like 100 shares and as you
go out of the money they decrease um and
so whenever like let's say you buy an
out the money option it's going to be uh
approximately simulating 50 shares um if
as that option goes in the money it's
going to progressively simulate 55
shares 60 shares 65 70 right so not only
is the option going to get more valuable
um but the rate at which its value is
increasing is also going to increase um
that's why you know derivatives right
the rate of like the rate of change is
relevant and the rate of change of the
rate of change is relevant um
so uh Delta essentially is going to tell
you um how many shares your option is
going to simulate um and Gamma is going
to tell you uh the rate of change of
your Delta with respect to price in
other words if you want an option that
is going to whose Delta is going to
increase the most for removing the
underlying then you want an option with
maximum
gamma um so I'm actually going to hop
over to some curves so that we can
understand
that um sorry very intense white screen
but okay so gamma versus call Delta
again we're going to stick with calls
just for Simplicity s sake one second
I'm going to drink some
coffee all right
so
uh your gamma curve is going to look
like this bell curve over here right and
the center of it um it doesn't say here
but the stock price at this in this
particular example is around 25 um and
so your maximum gamma and this should
kind of make sense intuitively is
actually going to be the at the money
call or the at the money put and the
reason for that is because that th those
options are on the inflection point of
either being worth a lot or being
completely worthless um so that's the
maximum gamma that is the point at which
the Delta will inflect and start to
either increase rapidly or diminish
rapidly um if you look at this Delta
curve and again this is a Delta curve
for a call specifically you can tell
that um and I think that oh this is
gamma Val in any case right here this is
going to be around 0.5 Delta because
it's at the money and then um as it goes
in the money um it's going to ramp all
the way up to one so oh yeah so they
have this axis actually does the Delta
properly yeah um and so there's this
inflection point right here of the Delta
curve um which is the share simulation
uh aspect of the option and that
inflection point is very very well
captured or it's precisely what gamma
captures it tells you at what Point um
is this option going to either be worth
a lot or be worthless at what point is
it capable of um it's not quite but we
can think about it like exponential
movement right um and the reason that
this is important is hey what if you're
an option seller right what if you have
the obligation you're on the other side
of that and you have the obligation to
deal with whatever happens to that
option well then the maximum gamma is
the point at which you have maximum risk
because the call option and the in this
case the call option um could go from
being worth the little bit that you sold
it to all of a sudden being worth a ton
or it could become worthless um but this
is your point of Maximum risk and that's
why we're interested in gamma okay now
we're going to make the transition from
gamma to gamma
exposure so all of you will remember
hopefully that when we were looking at
this option chain right I was talking
about um open interest right here an
open interest uh uh designates
specifically the number of of contracts
that are left o left open from the
previous day of trading um so typical
gam exposure all it does is it grabs
this open interest um it multiplies it
by the gamma right because we want to
see okay um not only do we want to see
what's the point of Maximum exposure but
we want to adjust that point of Maximum
exposure for how many contracts are
there actually there um and then we'll
also multiply it by a factor that'll
tell us um what the hedging obligations
would be
um if uh if price were to move um so uh
and this is like pretty pretty much
common knowledge if you look at here
like this is a you know one place to
find the calculation it's just options
gamma um this is the total gamma
contribution for each option and then
we'll move down to the next part so
options gamma times contract size um
times open interest so contract size for
SPX is just 100 all the time for most
options it's just 100 open interest
which is what we just talked about time
spot price
um and this is just a matter of
convention but usually we use positive
one if calls and negative 1 it puts and
if you look over I'm going to hop over
to gbot for a second um so you can see
gamma exposure over here it's in
billions because we haven't done the
final adjustment but negative over here
so these are puts and positive over here
and right like this is our histogram all
of our strikes calls over here puts over
here um the other thing that we're
actually missing here is what we want to
do we know that the gamma of puts and
calls actually cancel each other out
because the curves look the same so
what's really nice that we can do is we
can literally take this open interest
right this open interest do the gamma
multiplication offset them from each
other to figure out how much exposure
there is at that particular strike um
and that's actually how we get to gamma
exposure um with this final little bit
of
um multiplying here so I'm not really
going to get into the um very specific
um dimensions of how how the math is
done um but uh and this is actually
quite useful I think uh he puts it here
in plain English option dealers need to
sell uh and by dealers he's he's saying
people on the other side of the people
who own those options need to sell 19
billion worth of SPX index for each 1%
move down and buy 19 billion for each 1%
move up according to those open interest
numbers multiplied by the gamma exposure
um right this is if they want to stay
Delta hedged essentially um so um yeah
that was a really quick intense
introduction hopefully these resources
are all you know uh relatively clear um
so the point is and I'm going to go back
to gex spot now
that uh and I'll be clear as well the
open interest that we're talking about
right now because we haven't moved on to
gex by volume is the red uh so open
interest is uh what we see at the
beginning of the day so let me scroll
all the way back to the beginning of the
day and you can see how at the beginning
of the day we only have open interest
numbers because no volume has entered
the picture right and so if we were to
look here we have multiple things that
are happening right just to remind you
we have call open interest put open
Interest being multiplied by their
respective
gamas um then being multiplied as well
um by I'm pretty sure it's a spot Square
because I think that gspot uses actually
uh coincidentally the same um yeah it's
the same methodology as this particular
site so uh what's going to happen is
um these bars are indicating um how much
dealers are going to need to
hedge um given where spot is right um
so and the bars are going to change as
well because the gamma of these specific
strikes is going to change as either
spot spot moves up or spot moves down so
for instance let's say that just keep an
eye on the red bars for this in fact
maybe what I can do is I'll turn off gex
by
volume can I do
that uh I don't think I can actually
turn it off yeah I can't turn it off in
the historical um in any case if you
look at um we'll we'll we'll observe how
what happens as spot moves right so spot
moves uh again oh sorry spot price is
this 48320 it's this kind of line here
um so yeah anyway it's
coming
[Music]
uh there you go as spot moves down see
how the 4050 strike expanded it's
because it became closer to at the money
so the gamma of that particular strike
expanded so the hedging obligations for
people who are on the other side of that
strike are increasing as price is coming
down uh in fact we can we can quantify
it right um they started around 2.5
billion and then they ended up going
to you know by 10:30 it was more like
you know 3.9 4 billion um so uh yeah
that's that's gamma exposure by open
interest so uh one issue that we have is
that well open interest just tells us
the uh open contracts from yesterday it
doesn't tell us what the hell is going
on today um and so what gex spot does is
it makes the naive assumption that um uh
well the way that they put it is uh all
calls are bought outputs are sold but it
doesn't really matter they basically
just take like all the volume as if it
were opening volume um and so then they
perform the same calculation except they
use the uh volume column here so volume
here volume here
um and what that does is it basically um
just assumes that every single oh that
that's what I meant to say it assumes
that every single transaction that
occurs is to open a contract um rather
than to close a contract so as we see
the day progressing you can see how
these maroon bars here are actually
growing and growing and growing and
growing um and some of that has to do
with where spot is moving right because
of course Max gamma is always going to
be the strikes right on spot because
those options could either be worth a
ton or be worth nothing um so it's the
inflection point like I was talking
about before but another part of These
Bars growing and you can see hey the 40
50s in volume are are growing a lot as
well uh the the second component that's
making these bars grow is that volume is
coming in uh and more options are being
transacted at those particular strikes
um and so this is giving us a pretty
good understanding for how exposure is
changing over the course of the day now
of course um it is not the case that
every single transaction is to open a
contract it's not as if contracts are
just being added and added and add it
some people are bailing on their
contracts from yesterday or bailing on
their contracts in day um and closing
them um but that's something that's
that's very very difficult information
to gather and what uh gex spot uh has
noticed what I've noticed as well is
that the this particular methodology
actually gives you a very very solid
idea and you have to use a little bit of
your intuition so for instance um if I
see that this 4100 call strike is
growing in volume which it has been um
and let's say that at the same time as I
see it's growing in volume spot price is
actually falling away from it um then it
makes sense to infer that a good number
of those transactions are likely sells
right so people are getting out of them
or even selling to open those uh they're
selling those options essentially um so
you have to spend some time with the
tool to figure out to to start to see
okay well how does um uh how do these
volume gam exposure by volume nodes
interact with price uh and then you can
start to build up an intuition um for
for how that is a lot of times for
instance this is a really good example I
think in the interview with Jasper we
were talking about this um if you see
price just
consolidating um and a node that's
pretty far out of the money like let's
say this 4100 is just growing and
growing and growing in gam exposure by
volume um then it's a pretty solid
indication that people are actually
adding to it right uh usually you don't
you only really see people bailing out
of calls if price is actually moving
away from that strike and so it means oh
they're loading into it so somebody
knows something that I don't and they're
likely loading into 4100 calls because
we're going to make a move up there um
do I think that that's the case today uh
honestly I'd have to check but it
actually looks like it might be yeah
because price has been consolidating um
it would not be unreasonable to expect a
move uh to either 490 or 4100 by the end
of the day but you know still early in
the day so who knows
um all right let me think if there's
anything that I have missed um in terms
of the
why uh I think that's pretty solid
there's some there's some little a few
informational points to make here so for
instance um when I'm looking at this
option chain right over here that I was
using as an example um this is just
calls and puts for Wednesday April 26 um
but what um what gex spot actually does
is it synthesiz izes the entire option
chain so it's taking every single
expiration and blending it all into uh
this one thing that we see and they're
they're currently working on
um they're currently working on
isolating just zero data expiration uh
gex because it's so relevant but I will
say that it doesn't necessarily matter
that much because and this is something
that I don't really necessarily have up
but intuitively you can kind of
understand that right Gam is so intense
for at the money options because they're
at that inflection point of either being
worth a lot or worth nothing um but as
you go further out in time gamma
actually diminishes significantly
because um there's more time until that
option is either worth a lot or worth
nothing so it's no longer quite on at
that same inflection point the real
inflection point happens with the really
short dated options um so you'll see
that when you eventually when this
feature gets implemented and you switch
between zero DTE options and you know
the rest of the entire synthesized
option chain you'll see that there's not
actually a huge difference uh in terms
of gamma exposure and um you know that
may change going forward as uh if people
start to move out of
um move away from uh zero DTE options
into other options but um for now uh
that's sort of just how it is um all
right um I just wanted to uh go run
through a couple of the sort of more
visual aspects of the Tool uh before
moving on to looking at
SPX um so I'm just going to run through
this uh in case there are any questions
that come up so in this sidebar right we
have the date just to make sure that
we're time spot price so that's spot
price of SPX um we also have um this
whole part of this whole box here is for
gamma exposure by volume right and then
we have zero gamma um and zero gamma is
uh essentially if so let's say I start
at the bottom of the chain right and
then I'm work my way up and so I add
this strike to this strike to this
strike to this strike to this strike
going all the way up and like these are
all negative right so it's like uh some
negative number negative number negative
number and then I have and then I I move
up here and then I get positive numbers
up here it's basically trying to find
what you would call the flip point at
which um or the balance point where all
of the positive stuff is offsetting all
the negative stuff um that's zero gamma
um or zero gamma by volume uh of course
would be using these red bars zero gamma
by open interest which is um I actually
don't think they have it on here but um
it would be the same thing just using
these uh the red bars instead uh that
level can actually be quite significant
because it will tell you whether the
overall complex like whether hedging
pressure coming from the overall complex
is tending towards pushing price down or
uh pushing price up um so it's sort of a
uh a a really good way to get into for
what is the midpoint right of the day
kind of um it's kind of like a a gamma
type of vwap if you've ever used that
right um so okay um then major positive
gamma is just literally the largest
gamma node and we can tell right now
it's 40 it's say 4089 it's really the
409s um which which are right here and
you can see that um and then major
negative same thing for the negative
it's the 470 these are kind of the guard
rails for price over the course of the
day like if price gets under 470 or
above 49 90 you should expect some
fireworks like it's going to really
start to move in that direction um
because of course uh the uh people who
sold all those options will be caught
off sides they'll have to hedge and then
it'll be either gamma squeeze up or
gamma squeeze down um so it's nice to
have those two guard rails um and then
net gex is just whether the overall
complex like if I were to add every
single bar do we have more negative or
more positive in this case today we have
you know we have more negative um so the
next thing I want to get to and this is
actually a very I think underutilized
one of the most interesting and
important features of gex spot um and
it's these dots here right so um the
dots allow you to see uh and it says it
here uh let me actually pull up this
little color thingy here so you can see
how it's different shades of blue and
you can change those colors obviously 1
minute 5 minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes
30 minutes um and so it tells you um has
this bar been diminishing or increasing
over the course of the last few minutes
so it's essentially performs the same
function as this history slider that
lets you see okay how did gamma exposure
change over the course of the day which
is really cool by the way I'm just going
to slide it slowly so you guys can take
a look um and you can see oh wow those
4100s were really growing for a while
really growing for a while and now they
started to kind of taper off there
um very cool actually it kept on growing
all
day oh and they only started to taper
off around 12:30 okay um let's get back
to live actually okay in any
case uh these uh these dots allow you to
see um that sort of temporal Dimension
uh right now so I can see okay where was
the 4100 five minutes ago is it has it
increased or diminished since in the
last half hour uh and that can be really
important information because especially
like I was talking about before if you
see that
um that for instance the bar like the
dots are all on the inside then you can
tell that it's been growing consistently
over the course of the last half hour um
whereas if all the dots are on the
outside you can tell oh it's been
shrinking consistently over the course
of all the last half hour and by inside
outside I mean whether the dots are
embedded in the bar or whether they're
um sort of in the space behind the bar
or outside the bar um and so you can get
a sense for whether uh obligations are
increasing or diminishing at that
strike so that first part of the video
that was the vegetables so to speak
we're eating our vegetables figuring out
um the basis for uh this fun chart and
this part of the video is just going to
be about um how price responds and moves
around gamma I broke it up so we're
actually further in uh this is just
about we're just near the close here of
the day today is the 26th if if
anybody's wondering um but I'm actually
going to start by going back a little
bit and so to around where we were
earlier in the day so we're going to
load
today uh let's go back to what we were
talking about before and we were looking
at those
409s
um so given what we know about Gamma
exposure and hedging obligations we can
sort of start to infer uh how pric is
going to behave around a given strike
and for that I'm going to go uh over to
this chart again
um and so right if maximum risk for an
option seller uh is right here um then
anything coming up to the at the money
is increasing increasing risk and then
anything beyond here is decreasing risk
um so this is why a lot of times um
you'll actually see for instance if
we're focusing on uh okay maybe for the
purposes of this this part of the video
we'll talk about the 4100 if we're
focusing on the 4100 and assume get rid
of all these other strikes like let's
just think about this one isolated
strike this one isolated curve um as
we're coming
up uh the risk for uh holders or or for
the sellers of this 4100 uh call
contract is increasing and it's
increasing because the gamma's
increasing like this right until we get
to 4100 um so they actually are being
forced to buy Deltas all the way into
4100 which is what they're going to be
doing buying Deltas um which is going to
push price even further into 4100 but as
soon as we've hit
4100 um they're no longer they're uh
risk uh in in terms of pure Deltas it's
still increasing if price passes the
4100 strike but in terms of the rate at
which uh those Deltas are increasing uh
their risk is actually diminishing
because the gamma is actually tapering
off right and so you can see that in
this Delta curve quite clearly where um
the rate at which the Delta is
increasing is itself increasing until
around here and then all of a sudden it
starts to taper off so what that means
is that once we've already hit the 4100
strike uh there is not as much of an
incentive to uh push price Beyond it
which is why these big gamma nodes tend
to be quite sticky or these big gamma
strikes tend to be quite sticky in fact
the only way that we can really get
beyond the 4100 is if people start to
liquidate their 4100s and Pile in the
415s um or they don't even need to
liquidate the 4100s they can hold on to
them but we essentially need enough
people buying the 415s that we get this
sort of lading effect where um all of a
sudden um there's a new gamma curve uh
that's uh principally moving spot and
that gamma curve is sort of like the
next the next magnet essentially right
um so we can kind of think about it like
that right like with at least for the
for the purposes of uh a call if we're
underneath that call and that call is
being added to um then it actually from
a gam exposure perspective is pulling us
up and then as soon as we get above it
uh again because the gamma of that
particular strike is actually going to
be diminishing the further we move away
from it um it is actually pulling us
back down so attraction below um and uh
and actually attraction above too right
um and something similar can be said for
put strikes right um with with this 4050
right if people are piling into the 4050
and they're increasing risk at the 4050
level um then hedging out that risk is
going to drive us closer to 4050 uh but
once we've already passed
450 um it no longer acts in the same way
that being said the behavior of call
gamma and put gamma is slightly
different because um you have a
volatility component which maybe I'll
get to uh in another video uh that's a
little more complicated right because
typically as price moves up volatility
contracts and as price move down moves
down volatility expands um so um the
this 4050 once we pass it it has
slightly less of a tendency uh to act as
a magnet
um from underneath right if spot is
trading underneath a big put strike um
it's actually more likely to continue
lower uh rather than to hang out right
underneath that put strike if it's above
that put strike then that's a completely
different issue um but in general we can
say that these
um that
uh we can look at these uh big strikes
as magnets um and think about them also
sort of in the sense of um one one one
of the experiments I like to um I like
to kind of run in my brain is just to
think about all these strikes as a ton
of superimposed gamma curves on on each
other right so you'd have to draw a
gamma curve around here around the 4110
around the 4105 around the 4100 probably
a bigger one over the
4100 and then this chart is actually
just showing us a ton of those gamma
curves superimposed on one another um
and so if you were to imagine and there
are charts out there that do this as
well um for instance like I think that
spot gamma has uh has one and it kind of
shows you Peaks and valys so to speak
but um in this particular case the run
up to the magnet here or the magnet Zone
around 4090 and
4085 um and then to 4100 it seems to be
like highly incentivized but then it
seems to be very very difficult to get
above and over right um so it's almost
like there's an easy ramp up but then
it's harder to get over that Peak right
the like gamma Peak so to speak um in
any case uh that's probably a a pretty
decent way to at least start thinking
about how uh these strikes affect the
movement of spot um the last thing that
I'm going to get into is just that
there's a little bit of reflexivity
going on here so um if multiple Market
participants know that 4100 is likely to
be a sticking point many participants
who have calls uh that are 4100 calls
are likely to liquidate when we reach
that level um and so that also makes
right and this is this is how uh these
gamma
exposure profiles end up operating
somewhat like uh General uh Market
volume profiles right uh because there
there is that reflexivity involved there
and then another component um which kind
of adds to that is that let's say that
I'm buying an option right and I think
that uh the Market's going to go up
really you know it's going to go up a
certain amount then I'm most
incentivized to hold an option for this
zone between right around this amount of
gamma and this amount of gamma right so
I want maximum gamma um because it's
giving the maximum amount of convexity
to my option as soon as we as we've hit
like as soon as my option goes in the
money even by a little bit then all of a
sudden I'm in a completely different
situation because um I'm no longer
getting the maximum convexity from that
option now I could have a different sort
of strategy which recommends holding on
to that option for some other reason um
but if I'm just playing the move then
that option is not the most efficient
one to hold on to anymore so either I
need to move to another option uh which
is going to be over here let's say so
that I can ride this what I call the
gamma ramp again um or I need to
liquidate that option so that's another
uh aspect of uh not so much reflex
reflexivity but just Market structure or
options pricing structure that ends up
making it such that we have a tendency
to stick around large gamma nodes um
which going back to the beginning of the
video is why I was talking about um you
know these as guard rails as major
negative and major positive gamma as
guard rails for the General market and
even more broadly why a lot of the times
this zero gamma can operate as sort of a
balance point for the overall
Market yeah in any case um in another
video I'll get into some of the more
complicated aspects especially going
into the close I mean you guys can see
that things get pretty crazy as we go
into the close um even not zoomed in all
the way let me actually scale it down a
little bit so you guys can see how crazy
that is
um but um also it's not a coincidence
right that we saw that 40 50s were
building we we ended up right on major
negative gamma pinning major negative
gamma for the day but that's again
that's the topic for another video um so
there I'll talk a little bit about what
what I was hinting at with regards to
the role that uh volatility expansion or
contraction can play into navigating uh
gex and then also the effect of theta or
time Decay um on a lot of these gamma
strikes um and how that influences the M
spot but yeah I hope you guys enjoyed
this one um and uh like And subscribe
and I'll see you in the next
one